And finally, new rule:
Republicans have to stop
pretending they hate it
when celebrities give
their political opinions.
Please, you're the party
that made Reagan president!
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
It's...
It's not our fault
that your celebrities
are Ted Nugent,
Pat Sajak and Donald Trump.
(LAUGHTER)
James Woods? His last credit
was on a Mastercard bill.
(AUDIENCE GASPING)
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
Scott Baio? The only thing
he's been in recently
that made headlines
was his co-star.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
Antonio Sabàto Jr.
was an underwear model
who all the other
underwear models referred to
as "the dumb one."
(LAUGHTER)
And after he spoke at the last
republican convention,
he claimed he was blacklisted
in Hollywood.
Blacklisted?
Blacklist would be an upgrade.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
He wasn't on any list.
He'd be lucky to get on
a "Do not call" list.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
You'd have to run him
into show business.
(LAUGHTER)
And he's running
for congress now,
as is clueless
actress Stacey Dash...
who was also in the movie
Clueless.
(LAUGHTER)
At Obama's inaugural gala,
he had
Beyoncé, Springsteen,
Sheryl Crow, Bon Jovi,
Mellencamp, Usher,
Stevie Wonder, Garth Brooks,
Tom Hanks, Denzel and U2.
Trump's inauguration...
had Jackie Evancho
and the rock band
Three Doors Down.
(LAUGHTER)
As in,
three doors down from fame.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
And then there's Dana Loesch,
who America has come to know
as the fiery voice of the NRA,
blaming gun violence
and all our problems
on Hollywood and its liberalism.
They use their movie stars,
and singers, and comedy shows,
and award shows to repeat
their narrative
over and over again.
Fight this violence of lies
with the clenched fist of truth.
(LAUGHTER)
Yes, yes,
I know what you're thinking.
"Who hurt you, Danica Patrick?"
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
What you may not... (LAUGHS)
...know about Dana Loesch
is that before her job
as NRA spokesmodel,
she was a show business wannabe,
a homemaker in St. Louis
with a mommy blog,
and a radio show,
and dreams of TV stardom.
NCIS producer Paul Guyot says
that ten years ago,
Dana pitched him a sitcom
starring herself as, quote,
"a hot, young mom who does
a far-right radio show."
Think Frasier meets awful.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
And you know what? If only
they had made that sitcom,
today, she might be
a completely normal person.
(LAUGHTER)
Instead, we're all getting
the "clenched fist of truth,"
because show business gave her
the raised finger of "fuck off."
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
The same thing happened to both
the founder of the right-wing
Breitbart website,
Andrew Breitbart,
who admits he came
to Hollywood "with the hope
that I'd eventually become
a comedy writer,"
and to his successor there,
Steve Bannon,
also a showbiz reject
who didn't have the talent
to cut it here,
and so spent the rest
of his life hating Hollywood
and, by extension, all liberals.
In his memoir, Breitbart
mentions Reagan six times,
-and me 34 times.
-(LAUGHTER)
True. He called celebrities
"elitist pestilence,
with their cocktail parties
on the West Side."
"God, I fucking hate them,"
he said.
Which is funny,
because, you know, for years,
you know who I'd always see
at cocktail parties
on the West Side?
Andrew Breitbart.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
Oh, he...
He hated Hollywood.
Hated it, hated it, hated it!
Mostly from his home in
America's heartland, Brentwood.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE
AND CHEERING)
As for Bannon, George Clooney
remembers him as, quote,
-"a schmuck who--" (LAUGHS)
-(LAUGHTER)
"...who literally tried
everything he could
to sell scripts."
Including, this is true,
a rap musical
of Shakespeare's Coriolanus.
Think Hamilton, but instead
of Founding Fathers, Romans,
and instead of
cultural phenomenon,
piece of shit.
(LAUGHTER)
Bannon lost his shirt
on that deal,
but luckily, he was wearing
three more. But--
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
But trust me, if Bannon
could've sold a screenplay,
or Breitbart, a sitcom,
they wouldn't have ended up
ranting and raving
about cocktail parties
on the West Side.
They'd be attending them
and, in Bannon's case,
finishing the drinks
people left on the table.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-Including the ones with
a cigarette in them. And so--
-(LAUGHTER AND GROANING)
That is why I implore, tonight,
all Hollywood execs:
next time a conservative
comes to you
with a really dumb idea
for a movie or a TV show,
just fucking do it.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE
AND CHEERING)
We... (LAUGHS)
We need affirmative action
for Republicans
in show business.
They're not good enough
to make it on their own,
but if we give them a leg up,
maybe they won't
take their rejection out
on the whole country.
Huh, people?